[Musique]
devenir un enfant de 2 ans tenter de
grimper sur une chaise de se servir à
boire ou d'aller aux toilettes
une activité ludique proposée aux
visiteurs du forum de la parentalité à
la verrière objectif prévenir des
accidents domestiques responsable de 20
mille décès chaque année dont 40 %
d'enfants
alors en fait l'enfant la première chose
qui va voir c'est là que de casseroles
dans ce sens la première chose il va
être attiré par ce qui est à l'intérieur
donc il va appuyer voyez avec un seul
doigt j'arrive appuyé sur la casserole
et malheureusement la première chose qui
va lui arriver c'est que le liquide
coule sur sa tête et sur les réseaux de
parties du corps donc c'est des brûlures
minimum au deuxième degré pour un enfant
une quinzaine d'exposants des acteurs de
la santé du social ou encore de
l'éducation
l'association dix fois plus fort est
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement des
enfants ayant des troubles de
l'apprentissage
souvent c'est des problèmes de consigner
bien dire les consignes une par une ces
aussi mettre en place des petits
pictogrammes pour que les enfants
puissent avoir des repères et puis c'est
aussi pas faire preuve de patience de la
part des parents c'est un événement
nouveau sur la ville mais on pense que
effectivement sur une ville où beaucoup
de parents sont deux familles sont
monoparentales notamment ça peut être
intéressant d'avoir comme ça à un
endroit où on va retrouver un peu tous
les sujets de la vie de l'enfant
une vie dans laquelle les parents ont pu
se plonger durant un après midi tout en
bénéficiant de conseils pour l'éducation
de leurs enfants